hello dr. Burke here listen I'm going to
talk about what to do if you have an
extremely slow thyroid or you had your
thyroid removed and you're trying to
lose weight and nothing is working
there's a lot of things you can do that
are insignificant I'm going to talk
about the most important thing that you
should do let's talk about the things
that are important but not the top the
list you know getting iodine from seek
help it's not a bad idea you should do
that but it's not going to be the main
thing
selenium important you might see some
improvement but it's not going to be
earth-shattering exercise it might help
you a little bit but it's not going to
be like gigantic I mean the type of
exercise that a thyroid person needs to
do would be a bit of a higher intense
short duration type exercise you see
youtube views the problem the thyroid
hormones control and coordinate every
cell and the entire body it controls the
metabolic rate how fast that you break
down fat so that thing is slow you can
imagine you're up against your own
metabolism so it controls the metabolic
rate
it controls the night or a number of
mitochondria those are the energy
factories that actually burn fuel also
controls hundreds of intracellular
enzyme in the formation of protein hair
nail skin so you can imagine so many
things are connected to that thyroid
okay so the thing that you have to do is
you have to as a primary thing switch
from glucose fuel to ketone fuel or fat
fuel that's really the only thing to do
because that is a much more efficient
fuel source and it's fat burning so here
you are trying to lose weight wouldn't
it be a good idea to actually have your
body only burn fat so that's one thing
you have to do is transition over it
takes about a good six weeks or more to
fully adapt your body to burning fat
okay and you're going to use two
specific techniques ketosis and the most
important one which is in a minute
fasting
okay so intermittent fasting is going to
be your best tool to do this but it's
going to have to be done a little bit
extreme but just hang on let me just
kind of explain first the first thing
you want to do just to make this really
easy and a really nice gradual process
to start with three meals a day no
snacking okay I'm going to put some
links down below on more details on that
but three meals a day no snacking okay
you do that for three weeks now what's
going to happen is your body is going to
start to adapt to fat burning because
every time you eat you stimulate insulin
and insulin is what's really keeping you
from switching over to fast fuel okay
now your two meals a day okay you're
maybe at a late lunch or a lunch and
then you're headed early dinner that's
the ideal scene and two meals a day
after three weeks that's going to give
you a chance to drop insulin all the way
by the time you your last meal all the
way to the next meal you're going to be
able to heal insulin that's going to
greatly speed up your metabolism right
there okay now in three more weeks
you're going to have to do this next
step which is going to go to one meal a
day I don't recommend this for the
majority of people only for those people
that have thyroid issues that have a
really really slow metabolism from
whatever reason maybe they had the
thyroid removed maybe they just end up
with a damaged thyroid from some low
calorie diet long time ago but one meal
a day and don't feel like you're going
to starve on that because I know of
bodybuilders incredibly large men that
actually do one meal a day
now the meal that you eat on that this
is the goal by the way to get one to one
mil a day because that's what you're
going to have to do to be able to get
the weight off but you're going to have
it's going to be a nutrient dense huge
meal so you're going to get all your
nutrients for that meal but it's going
to be one
Daniel snacks and you have to work up to
it over a period of time that's what
you're going to do to actually see
changes because you're missing a real
key piece of the puzzle in the chain of
endocrine glands and you have to work on
other things to make up that missing
link by just leveraging intermittent
fasting to the extreme of course you're
also going to be doing ketosis healthy
ketosis where you're going to be doing
like low sugars and no fruits and things
like that but you're going to be able to
eat some healthy fats but this will
greatly help you so combination of
ketosis and Internet fasting very
important but intermittent fasting is
the number one important thing ketosis
number two and then these are next okay
so I put some links down below check it
out but that's what you have to do if
you've tried everything nothing's work
and you're at you're like wit's end and
you just can't do anything and you know
you need to take to the next level okay
this will work thanks for watching hi
guys hey listen I created a pretty
amazing evaluation quiz down below that
actually analyzes your symptoms to find
the cause the root cause of all of your
symptoms the most likely cause so take
the quiz now and we'll send you a report